Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7.
Now, there's been brand spankin' new DLC added to the game.
First starting off with "Not A Hero"
which is a DLC that was planned for... I believe this spring, but it was way delayed
and then "End of Zoe" which is a story of Joe Baker, Jack's unheard-of brother.
So we're gonna start with Not a Hero because it says "weeks after Not a Hero"
so I'm assuming that Not A Hero needs to be played first,
but I am gonna play both so don't you worry...
About that...
Let's see what's awaiting. It's been--
Oh hey, okay.
Alrighty then... Normal... I'm real good at this game
Oh, it's this guy. "Chris Redfield is a high-profile BSAA member who has resolved many a bio-terrorism crisis over his length--"
Alright then.
Heeeehhh
Hmm, 'kay.
Helluh?
That's a close-up of a nose.
Alri-- Ohhh! Wait, am I gonna be playing as you?
Never mind that I don't even remember your name, it's been so long! Well, Hi, Bye. Okay. See you.
aaaAAAaaah.
Oh, this is immediately after the main game just ended, after you fight, uh
The little grandma lady girl... thing, whatever you would call it.
Euh.
Oh now I'm gonna kick some ass. Aw, it's-- gah, it's been so long since I've been in this game!
Oh, I love it!
I love this game to death. I played it a lot in my spare time, too,
like the unlimited modes that they had were really fun.
HO BOI, I get an armor system! Umbrella? I bet this isn't gonna infect me.
Yeah I am...
ooOOOOooo am I?
Ah...
Ohkeh
Yeah... by myself-- if three people died then I'm sure to do fine on my own.
Oh this is gonna be go-good.
Oh god. It's been so long!
I don't even remember how to play!
HE HE HE
HEEEEE
Do I have like a-
Ha ha ha yeah combat knife. Okay, so I got that, I got this, I got a grenade...
Three of those okay, all right, let's do this!
Let's do this. It's been a while since I played but- block- okay blocks still the same.
Hup pe doop pee
Come aww- WOAH!
You want some!? You want some?
BAP
BLAP
Yeah, you want some more?
Blap!
Hohoho hoh!
Popped like a red balloon.
You can punch enemies when they stagger--- how do I punch...?
Is there a button for punching-- well, that's a reload-
WOAH!
Hey!
Imma punch you with THI-
[Redfield PUNCH]
W O A H !
Who-- Whoaa!
I punched the shit out of you! [giggling]
I didn't expect my punch to be that potent--
I'm sorry about that, excuse you, I was interrupted.
I'll punch him later.
There's a pr...
problem with the punching trainer- woah OH.
Uh oh...
punch without-- oh! Ohohohohohohohohoo.
Ohh, so I don't even need to switch to my melee.
Ohh, wait.
Damn it. God damn it... I just wasted some bullets on you assholes.
That's fine. I think I know what I'm doing.
Yeah, I rem--
Is it now?
Yeah, seems like he might be--
Oh now that you said that I'm pretty sure that's exactly what happened those men.
Uh-oh...
There we go, yeah.
Okay,
well...
Alright, let's see what you got. Chris Redfield on the job! Anybody wanna shooooty?
Who's moaning in the distance? And why isn't that moan not covered in bullets?
Hello, Lucas? Helloh? Do I remember how to open it-- OOOHHHHH I dewwwww.
Oh, hi, hello, are you dead or dying?
Why is it too late?
Little out of sync there, but okay.
Okay well, I think you already did it to the soldier friend there you asshole--
Oh
FUAHK
Well, that's not good, 'least it's just on my hand.
'Kay... Do I get out of here? Oh, I should, okay, I should probably skedaddle, huh?
I should probably move! I don't have time to look at things, work benches and the such like as-- ooh hello.
Whazzat?
Oh, thank you for watching on me. I don't need you to help me out. I know how to help me out...
That sucks.
Ah, yeah, okay.
It's...
ITZ JUZT AN ARM.
Don't you know I got goop juice to get that back on me?
Heh, you think I'm worried about that? Chris Redfield not worried about no--
Chris Redfield worried about you.
IMMA PUNCH
(Audible satisfaction)
That is such a pounch!
Alright. Bomp. Now I gotta wait for this bad boy.
Oh, no I don't, nevermind. It's instantaneous.
C'mon, c'mon, oxygen! Kind of a problem!
Alright
Man, why is he able to do that stuff? I thought all this stuff died when, you know.
Lady girl.
What's "The Connections"?
I still don't know why Chris is working with Umbrella, like, I don't know the timeline yet
I'm not a hundred percent sure where everything stands
but I guess we're probably gonna find out in this one if we're gonna play as Chris. Ooh. Hai!
Hai diddly ho dere!
I like the big red clown!
That's sumt'n I really liiiiike.
Well...Ooh, a save-y, okay so I'm gonna do that first obviously. Save, yes please. Thank you. Okay.
Anything in here? Oh a new coin, oh--
Ooooh!
Thank youu! I don't know what I'm gonna do with that. Also...Wait what is this stuff, eyy?
"A letter explaining Umbrella's new goals."
Mmmmmmmmokay. Alright. I dunno what- about that one.
Excuse me, I don't want you. Ah, here we go. Let's go to this one. Uh-huh uh-huh
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
"For many of you this is your first mission with us,
so we wanted to make it clear what Umbrella is all about. Though many of our staff hail from the infamous
pharmaceutical giant Umbrella, our purpose is to make amends for the atrocities perpetuated under the Umbrella name. That is why we
re-incorporated as a Private Military Company in 2007.
"We will put a stop to not only anyone who is engineering or selling bioweapons,
but those who support those efforts as well.
We made a mess and now we have to clean it up. By keeping the Umbrella name,
we show that we take responsibility for that mess and we want you to remember that you carry this responsibility with you in every mission."
Well that doesn't seem right! I don't- I don't think that's entirely true,
I don't- I don't believe you...
AT ALL, in fact. Okay. "Lurking Fear"?
Okay. "Operation Lurking Fear. Primary Mission: Extract Lucas Baker."
(Distant sound)
Sl-- Ooooh.
"Location: Dulvey, Louisiana. Baker estate. Threat pruh...Profile: 'Molded.' Alpha variant, others. Anti-personnel traps, lethal and non."
"Due to the lack of intelligence and the number of unknown factors involved, Chris Redfield of the BSAA will act as a bioweapons specialist on mission.
Recent intel's confirmed that Lucas Baper is holed up in the mines near the Baker estate."
"Lucas Baper." Whoa there was another page there! Wait.
Hang on...
...E-series model-- Eveline! EVELINE!
"--is present and active at the Baker estate. Lucas Baker seems to be monitoring her activities and reporting on her activities."
Okey-dokey then! Alright. Why? Let me push this button!
Coin.
Oh, I need a key. Okay, I see. All right.
Well, time to hit the old dusty trail.
Oh!
Oh sweet!
Oh, does that mean I should use this thing? Nah, that's just health.
Ah, I guess you're a permanent stat boost-- Ooh, hello.
Ah, frag grenadé. Good-- good for me, eh, huh?
Ehhh neh. Okay alright. I'm outta here!
I guess I gotta try to open these things, yeah?
That what I gotta dooooOOOOOOOoo.
Ah, hello. Welcome, me.
"Night vision device required"?
WHELP, AAH, I'M SCARED!
AAAAAHH
I don't have a night vision device! I didn't know if it was required or not. Kinda want to go in there without one but...
(High-pitched whine) I'll save it for later.
Nah, that's where I came from.
Okay. Let's try this one. It's green, m-means good!
Means beginner baby level I think.
Hello?
Anybody want to blow up the explosive on my arm, so I can reattach it with goop juice?
Anybody got any goop juice-- Please tell me I have goop juice! I don't want to dee-be using these injectors all day!
Oh that's stupid and terrible!
Uh-oh.
Hello?
Anybody? Welcome, me-- okay alright little weird.
Aah, the clown! I remember the clown, and its horrible machinations, okay, alright.
I don't have a key for you!
(murmuring) stupid...
Ooh, hello!
Ah, bio-weapon! Oh, dead body. Also bio-weapon!
Oh this is bad.
What do I do about this?
High-grade filter required? Uh-oh.
Wh-wha!? High-grade fi--
Oohh, screw you with your high-grade filter bullllllllshooty.
No no no don't kill me. Okay. Well. What do I gotta do?
"Analysis: Air clear." Oh, thank you for that. Man, this is a fancy weapon system I got here.
So what do I gotta go through-- Ooh.
Sorry that scared me. It scawed me.
I thought it was an enemy, but it turns out he was not. So there's gotta be somebody over here.
Maybe this one, up those stairs, maybe. Not sure. Is any of these that I can go in?
TELL ME YOUR SECRETS!
TELL ME-- oh, I don't like you sack. Tell me all your secrets!
Why do I gotta go in the bug area? Is that the secret?
I don't-- Ooh.
Hey, buddy
Okay, I don-- I guess you don't believe me?
But whatever it's gonna happen. Baby, you're gonna get out of here alive!
I know that Lucas guy. He don't like his games
You're gonna be fine. Okay, I guess I'll go down here. I have no basis for knowing that the key's down-- oH UP UP!
We're going up! All right. Up. Up is a thing. Okay. We're going up now. All right. I didn-- have no idea that the...
Ooh, behind! Okay, all right. I'm wrong in all fronts. I have no knowledge in this place,
I am just a visitor and an incredibly stupid one.
So who is here to try to take my life away from me?
Key? Uuuhhh
Whoa, ah, nope. Don't like that. All right. Well, going down this wa-- okay-- Oooh.
Ohoho, music.
Ah, hohoho.
How about wha-BLONK and then--
Pu-HUU-hunch--! Uh-oh.
EuuEEHugh.
*bonk*
Oh, you're not stunned!
*Block*
Ow.
Ahaah.
AAA-PUNCH-Y!
You want one?
Missed.
AAA-PUNCH-Y!
Okay, all right well is it-- Oh, is there more, okay. Well I got more punches for di--
This is how! This is how Chris Redfield got so jacked.
in Resident Evil 5 just like...
unbelievable amounts of-- Whoo, I'm gonna try to--
Aah shit.
Why can't I stomp on you? I was trying to stomp! Ah, I ran out of bullets.
Well that was dumb of me. Okay alright well... a-boomp.
No! Oh god, that didn't work!
Who'd 'a thunk? I'm gonna throw a grenade at you. Huh. Take some of that!
That'll learn you. Uh-oh, it didn't learn him.
Well, they've learned him that time
Alright, you done. Are you done? Are you done? Have you learned? Oh you haven't learned at all.
Alright well... Oh, come on, man!
No, you're not dead, ain't ya?
Ah, I got you that time!
He vanished! Why did he vanish?
I like this, uh, gun, it's a real, uh...
Real potent-- Ooh. Is it ticking? Wait.
No! Just not what I want!
I forgot that control is the...
Tick tock?
Okay. all right. I trust you. But barely, but not a lot, after my experiences with that-- whoa hey!
Naw, come on now. Haha, your head's gone.
Any more?
No no no it ain't gonna happen all right, so I took care of those guys. There's a clown door right there oh?
That's terrible okay well
Don't like that
Lucas you goof, man
Don't goof me like that ah you goofed me so thusly
oh
You're goofy. Okay. I see a gear is this what I need
What about a crank anybody got a cranky Yankee?
Everybody's seen one. I'm gonna put this on this, but all right gear glam well
Don't know handle though. Well. I got shotgun. I am I wanted I do that
Need some-else, mysteriously. I can't imagine what that might be
Couldn't be oh it couldn't be that thing up there could it
Bullets, thank you
Anybody else anybody else what's this antique coin yes, please, okay?
Whoa
Was that actually something or is
That a whole lot nothing neuro stun grenade. I don't need those. I just need old fashion bullets. That's all I've ever needed anyway
I saw to do it this oughta. Do it whoa oh, you know imma stop this wait
No, oh, oh hey. I want to stop this
Boy, oh, he's real. Smoky boy. Oh god. Why is he so good hey?
He's gonna charge apparently aah
Ah, I don't like that
You're gross, oh you're steamy boy
Yeah, "high regeneration target unaffected" oh
Okay, ah
He's a coming
He's coming around the mountain here. He comes oh
Okay, I'm gonna grab the key and I'm not giddy out of here. I guess "cell key"
Alright i'm out of here
I guess that's all I need right. I don't really need anything else remember just need a run right
Over there like an idiot, meanwhile I'm over here like a smart
Monk I'm sure this is gonna work. Oh
Wow, I guess I'm- this is the elevator of me being wrong. That's all this elevator is. I don't know what the heck
I'm doing in this el-. I got turned this way I'm
alright
Hello anybody in here anybody want to jump out of me here. We go who's he gonna work perfectly
Hello, oh, this is a trap oh, it's some kind of trap. Oh, no everything's all right now
That's just what he wants you to think
I'm just the bait
And you fell for it. Well. You could have told me
Man, oh boy. Oh, you could've told me about it
"Take the filter. On my mask"
"Hurry" Chris:"But you'll die"
Oh well that's no good
Geez geez oh geez oh
It's horrible well put it on what don't be sorry
Jesus
Lucas is an asshole, and I futile II got a high grade filter. Yeah that one guy had the high grade filter
Yeah, what contamination filter has been upgraded?
Alright, whatever god dammit. God dammit. That's son of a bitch I
Fine then I guess I'll go how much contamination stuff does this guy have why didn't he use it on, Ethan? Huh?
Damn alright whatever I'm out of bullets for that, but I got bullets for this I guess
Let me tell you all the things I'm gonna do with my hands to that asshole
Yeah, that's disappointing. I don't need those
Do I really need him alive though do we really I mean we could afford just a little bit of maiming
I mean you'll regenerate right
Oh mate, no isn't the curse like lifted or something, maybe he doesn't have special powers now
I'm not 100% sure about that, but I'm just gonna go on a wild guess
All right, who's down here. I hear something crawling
That's better still be open. Alright good. IT BETTER STILL BE OPEN! Alright good. Okay. Good good good
All right
Those look like mines, I probably shouldn't touch those Oh
Who's who goes there oh
You look a little different
Do you look a little different like crazy? Are you crazy? You look a little different? I don't like it oh
It's a shotgun
Suggestions
Ramrods?
Wha- ramrod?!
Ramrod??! Oh come on, why's it gotta be super advanced now? Awh man, Ethan got it easy
Ethan got it real easy. Awh this is stupid.
Awh this is dumb.
Someone gonna come hand-deliver it to me
or do I have to go back up and get it myself? is that- what, d'you have like a chute?
A pulley system that you can deliver it to me? so I don't have- my legs are sore from all my running
Just sayin'.
Where do I get it, O voice in the sky?
Where do I get this magical new equipment? Huh? Where's my ordinance?
Asshole. All right fine, I'll go back. I'll retreat for now
It's gotta be like an elevator or something- ouh.
Who be thunky-thunk out there? Don't think that you can be thunky-thunk when I'm in here.
Alright. Well, I'm falling back. Well that didn't work. Alright, well
Oookay, that did a whole lot of dick diddly. What am I supposed to do about that?
Where am I s'posed to go?
Hmm. I can't see any place to go, so... there's gotta be ramrods down here somewhere
I mean the only way to go is forward, so. There might be a way that I can get around that guy? I don't know..
Maybe like some space that I can make to surround him? 'Cause if I can do that, I can...
get a little bit of wide berth.
B-E-R-T-H, not birth.
Hello, are you still down here? You still down here? Better not be.
Yeah, you better not be. Oh no he's not down here. Oh, mysteriously. How strange.
How peculiar.
Okay, alright. Well, where are you?
I know he's gonna pop out at the the least expected moment. Right when I don't want him to.
Okaay...
Whatever you say, buddy.
Yeesh...
God, a lot of neuro stu-
Oh, neuro stun grenades would work on him, wouldn't they? Oh, if I can't shoot him then at least I can stun him, right?
I don't really need the... the that right now
Yeah, that looks good. Okay, I got it! whoa
Get neuro stunned, baby, ooh
neuro stun a punch
Regenerate that bitch. Oh it looks like he's regenerating that oh
These neuro stuns work a lot faster than I expected them to so did quite anticipate the sudden suddenness of it oh
Hey, hey whoa whoa that's horrible glass
neuro stun get punched oh
Shit, I just neuro stunned myself. Oh, this is dark. Well. Oh oh
Okay
Wasted in neuro sling grenade and incendiary what?
And incendiary who's he what's it? Where was all this good shit wouldn't when Ethan was walking around
Why are the ramrod bullets down here why are they down here?
All right cool ramrod bullets down here. It makes sense. It makes sense. It makes sense everybody it makes sense
Night-vision device SADS night-vision functionality to a none Briella night-vision device, so I'm out down here. Oh
I got night vision now. That's that's awfully nice. Oh
Wait how many ramrod bullets do I got here we go let me get my ramrod in here all right?
It's time to ram your rod
Little ram right here to show you a good time
Okay, is there like a way to turn on night vision, or is that just gonna activate automagically?
I'm gonna guess it's go
Is that good or bad
I'm gonna guess good. Cuz I like to look on the bright side of life
Hello, oh
Not good, not good. The answer is not good. Okay, I whoa
Wow
All righty, then whoo
Why does that look like it was equipped with a BAM
Tick-tock
Wait this isn't my knife. I would've thrown a neuro bomb at that
Also, this is very convenient incendiary grenades in grenade form here though. I woulda liked
Okay I
Don't hear no tick-tock
Haha, okay, all right anything else in there nothing all right down the hole. I'm Santa Claus. I went down a chimney
All right come a knife real sneaky-like
Lovely goop over there
Okay
What is all this then cause? I'm so weak from punching all these zombies all right. What about this
I'm not sure if this is good or bad what I just did
It's that good or bad I?
Can't tell
All right, whatever. I'm gonna hope for the best
Because I love Carla bright
Hello up down up oh
Okay, thanks for the
Thanks for the head. I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it. Okay. Oh
this
Is some outlet it looked like I pushed that up even though. I had to pull it somehow Chris Redfield
Just muscles it by pushing everything
Chris Redfield whoa whoa whoa whoa hey Oh
face humper hey hey hey
It's a freaking head pumper. Oh, no not my aunt owner. Oh grenade aah Frick. He used my good ammo
Damn it
That's what I get
All right, you know what I'm a knife up you and you I got even gonna waste bullets on you
Yeah, give me out of there. Hey
No, you want some no
Smash blam god. Oh god. They're so so fast
No
No no no no hey no, no no no no walk into my brood of death
No no my blade of death is what you walk into that now oh crap well, that's not good
Wait oh god. I killed like your whole family, and it's too there like Goku ah I want to shoot up
Hey, I get drugs. Oh
There we go
Whoa whoa Jesus sorry for the the nauseating movement here, no oh
Jeez can I go now can I go now? Oh, thank you Jesus? Ah no
Oh, you wanted to go toe-to-toe with me huh not today
not today
Okay
All right
What else do we have here
Lovely more okay. All right. You know what into my blade girls nope
Got him
Maybe I should just run for it oh
This is where the tour was ooh. That doesn't sound good
oh
Hey wait, I got super bullet for you one of them one bullet
Yeah, nailed it all
Right well that did the job one bullet
Amazing wish I had more of those. Whoa. Oh god. I did it again. Oh, why is control Hill?
Why I've just used all of my health like a idiot
Okay, all right. How do I get past you huh? I get past you
Oh
Like that all right well, okay, okay?
All right, then well, it's as easy as that oh hey
Miss me oh
Yeah get go get rekt get rekt
All right, I only got one bullet of this, but I got shout gun
That's awfully handy in a pinch
All right ooh. Do I hear another up there? Oh I hear something
There's something breathing hello
Okay, weird whoa hey whoa? Hey whoa? Hey whoa whoa whoa whoa?
Well come here shock him punch up or miss that's also an option boink
potato
No
You're done. Okay, you're down
It's amazing that it takes more shotgun bullets, and it takes actual normal bullets. Well. Those look those look active what duck
Oh, hey, how's it going? You're not gonna. Duck. Are you?
Okay, Oh
Got knocked down. Did you you get knocked down you get back up again. Okay? I
Am dead really what the hell no
If there are three turrets on the horizon, it's probably just better to look for a safer path oh really Wow mister condescending
Oh you think you're helping. Huh well screw you buddy screw you you know what i'ma throw a grenade at you guys
Oh come on
Well
God damn it
All right find that oh, yeah, it's gonna. Okay save for path you say
Whatever you think I don't know safe. I think I don't know about safety huh you gotta whoa Wow
Okay, run Howie oh
All righty, then man these turrets luck
Are they everywhere how many how many machine guns do I expect to believe that they had in this place?
Cuz goddamn, this is too many, and it doesn't even make sense
I know Lucas is supposed to be a genius and all that
Some kind of southern genius, but there's too much
Do much for my feeble mind to accept
I'm just backtracking now never get out of here
All right well I don't have I don't have the necessary thing to defeat to you
So I'm gonna
Somehow go around you
Huh, all right well
This is a conundrum
Yeah, I'm gonna just block. I'm blocking. Oh god. You really got it. You really got a cock block the coal-hole quarter
Oh, no, you didn't ha ha all right. I got it. I got it. I got a
Dick okay, all right what we got here. Oh, well. I don't sound good, but this sounds good, okay
Where am I now?
Bullets okay, I got bullets lots of all that's Oh should run okay lots of bullets. That's good
Yeah, man every time. I hold my gun to my face. I think that the bombs oh
Whoa whoa, whoa don't blow he's gotta blow hmm all right. That was scary why?
All right, okay weird oh hey oh, you're the weird one. Oh boy, okay, all right? Ah
I got you f okay
Oh boy, oh boy what am I wha why am I here? Why I'm here. Oh boy
Why I'm here hey hey hey, I don't want none. I don't want it. Oh
Okay all right wait there was something there oh
Okay, well this sucks where am I supposed to go then oh?
Geez oh, geez oh geez maybe I can blow up that barrel. Maybe I can blow up that barrel
Yeah, I won't blow up that barrel. Yeah, it's good plan mark. Yeah
Firestorm get can I stomp I was tough. No. I was trying to stop him. Oh
Oh follow up
Well that didn't work out - whoa hey, sorry about that I didn't work out do well for me, okay, all right
Well try one more time
Yeah, I don't have any more ramrod
I'm kind of a ram rotted out if you know what I mean
There's gotta be oh you yeah, you okay, all right, where was I
Try shotgun, Oh God
He doesn't get knocked over not even a knock over a me like a knock
Okay, well that was easy yeah, yeah
Okay, let me try to actually get the stew
How's it going okay, let me try to actually get the stomp on him actually you know
What do I even need to bother why do I need to bother I should just go this way. Hey, okay?
Okay, I'm out of here boom well alright. Then well that was easy
Okie dokie
Alright, well there you have it so anyway. That's all the time
I got for this one unless it's gonna be more story as soon as I get out here was there might be
Hello
No, okay, alright, so thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm gonna finish this up in the next episode of depending on how long it is there no idea honestly
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you
in the next video
BYE BYE :D